Thank you, everyone
who joined in today.
I really appreciate
your time and hope
that this can be a
productive time for all of us
as we spend some time talking
about R and Plumber together.
As Robert mentioned,
my name is James Blair.
I work as a solutions
engineer for RStudio.
And we're joined
on the line today
by Barret Schloerke who also
works here at RStudio
and is the primary maintainer
of the Plumber package
that is here to
help with questions
and provide some support
that way as well.
So we're grateful
for his presence
as well as we get started today.
Our topic today is
expanding our horizons
integrating our Plumber
APIs the idea here
is I am hopeful that this really
is an opportunity for if you've
never been exposed
to Plumber before.
I hope you find
something that's useful.
And if you've used
Plumber in the past
and have come to see
what's new with Plumber.
I also hope that there's
something useful.
So the ideal state here is
that everyone walks away
with something that's
beneficial for them
and that they feel like
they've learned just kind
of give you an idea of what
we're going to do today.
First, I want to set
the stage with a problem
that we're going to look at two
try to frame the conversation
that we have.
And then we'll have a brief
discussion about what an API is.
In case you're
unfamiliar and then
we'll talk about how you get
started using APIs with R
and the Plumber package.
And then we'll spend
some time discussing
some of the new features that
have been recently released
in the latest CRAN
version of Plumber.
And then finally, we'll conclude
by looking at different ways
that you can deploy these APIs.
So they can be widely
utilized either
inside of your organization
or by a broader audience.
And then at the end,
I'll provide some links
to additional resources
and like Robert mentioned,
this is being recorded.
Today's October 28 2020 so if
you're watching this recording
down the road, things may have
changed in the Plumber package.
And I'll show something
to you at the end
that can make sure you stay
up to date with the latest
changes.
And things like that.
But resources will
be provided if you
want to learn more today, we're
going to work with a data set.
This is the Palmer
Penguin's data set.
If you're unfamiliar this is a
fairly kind of recent to the R
space data set, you can
find some more information
at Alison Horst’s GitHub
repository that I
have linked here in the slides.
But basically, the
idea here is we
have 344 different
observations for three
different penguin
species: Chinstrap, Gentoo
and this Adelie.
And if you're familiar
with the iris data set
that the typical kind
of classification data
set you often see this is
a similar style data set.
Right fairly easy to
understand down here
on the bottom right
hand corner, you
can see kind of a preview
what the data looks like.
We've got the species
that island they came from.
Do we have some
different measurements
from each of these
different penguins.
Their bill length, bill
depth, flipper length, body
mass…
And then we have the sex of
the penguin and then the year
that the measurement took place.
So what we want
to do here is just
kind of frame this and this
could be any data set right.
This is the example that
we walk through today
is not specific to this
data set by any stretch
of the imagination.
But I think like
most data science
most analytical problems or
projects start with some data
and that felt like a natural
place to start today.
Let's start with some
data and go from there.
So what we want to
do now is we will
say we've been handed this data,
and we're going to go ahead
and we're going to do the
data science or in some cases,
you know means build
the model, and we're
going to take these
three or 44 observations.
This is not a model building or
necessarily data science themed
webinar.
So this is not about how to
build the best model possible.
This is just let's work with an
example that that's easy for us
to understand.
So we'll take the data you know
we might explore it clean it
up a little bit.
And then we'll fit
this model to it.
And the idea here is given
some set of measurements.
So given the bill
length, the bill depth,
the flipper length
and the body mass,
we want to predict the species
of that particular penguin.
Right and so that's what
we've done in the example
that we have pulled
up on screen.
We fit this model using
the tidymodels framework
and then we're able to see
some output from that model.
And now that we have this, we
can generate new predictions
right.
We can given a set
of new data that we
get a new set of
measurements from a penguin
of unknown species.
And we want to predict what
the species of penguin is.
We can pass those new
values through to the model
and generate a predicted
outcome in terms of what species
we think is that
penguin is likely to be.
Now this is all great,
but the question now
is kind of, well, now what, right?
We we have a couple of options.
Now now that we've
done our work.
We've built this model, we
have a few options ahead of us.
One is we can just
kind of ad hoc score
new penguin predictions
whenever we receive new data.
Right So maybe once a month.
We get an email from researchers
that are off researching
penguins and they send
us their new set of data
and we run that sort of
data through the model
in order to predict the species
of these new measurements.
That works right.
But maybe we want
something that's
a little bit more real time.
Maybe there's maybe
measurements are happening
at a pretty rapid rate.
And we don't want our
entire day job from here
on out to be predicting
penguin species using
the model that we built right.
But we also don't
want the model that we
built to just kind of
wither away and die.
We spend a lot of time here.
This was something that
we feel like contributes
to the goals of our business
or the goals of the project.
We're working on.
And we want to make sure that
it continues to contribute
in the best way possible.
But the problem is we're kind
of stuck because we either
have to be the
ones that generate
new values and new
predictions because we're
the ones that built the model.
And we know how to
use R or we have
to find somebody else
that knows are and can
do that themselves right.
So we maybe we email
them or we provide them
with access to the
model and they're
able to generate
their own predictions.
But that's still
kind of a high bar
because that means
that that person needs
to be able to open up an R
session and load our model
and load the data and run the
data through the model, which
if you're an R
user that's probably
not that big of a deal.
But if you're trying to teach
one of the business users
or one of end users of
your model how to run this
and you've got to teach them
about are now all the sudden,
this becomes a much larger task.
The other option is we
could just pass this off
to somebody else we could
say, OK, we've done our job.
Here's the model.
Here's kind of how
we set this up.
Now let's let that model
grow up quote unquote.
And we'll give it to
an engineering team
and they'll reconstruct
this model in a framework
that they're using.
So that it can be used for
real time scoring or real time
predicting of new data and that
that's a totally valid option,
but it's often a little bit
tricky to get that right.
Right to be able to hand
off the model in that way,
it's time consuming.
It it can be a
difficult process to go
through when in
reality, we already
have everything we need.
What we really need is just a
convenient way for other people
to be able to use our model.
And that's really
where APIs come in.
So let's take a step aside
from the model for a moment.
And let's just talk about
this notion of what an APIs
and in general, the API stands
for Application Programming
Interface.
Now that can mean a lot
of different things.
And in different contexts,
the idea of an API
can mean different things,
which makes it a little bit
difficult to understand.
And so for the purpose
of our conversation today
we're going to narrow
in on this definition
that we can get an APIs a web
API communicating over a HTTP.
And basically what that
is that provides us
with a standardized
way for different can
for different computers to
communicate with one another.
I get answer that.
And I'm not going to dive
into the nitty gritty details
of what makes up an API request
and what a response looks like.
There's lots of different
features involved here
that you can look
into and that and that
will provide some resources
that provide some detail there.
But the main idea
is when we talk
about web APIs over
HTTP, which is what we're
going to talk about today.
This is just a standardized
set way for different computers
to communicate.
Just like I'm communicating.
Now through my voice.
And then you're able
to understand computers
have their own way of
communicating HTTP web
APIs one of those mechanisms
for communication.
The idea is there's
a client that
sends a request that request
meets the standard of what
the server is expecting.
And then a server
receives that request
and then generates some
sort of a response.
And that response can
be something as simple
as, I received the request.
That's all that's all I need.
That's all I need to
do to something that's
much more complex like firing
off some sort of process
or updating a
database or generating
predictions against a model or
any number of different things
can happen in response to
a request that comes in,
but the server is responsible
for taking the request
and doing something with it.
And then providing a response.
And even if you've never really
interacted directly knowingly
with API in the past.
And it's interesting
to note that anytime
you use a lot of web browsers.
If you use Google Chrome
or Safari or Brave or Firefox
or anything like that.
And you visit a website.
There's a request
that your browser
makes to a server
that says, hey,
I'd like to view this web page.
That's that's at this address.
And the server responds with
typically a bunch of html
that your browser, then
renders for you to view.
So anytime you view
a website, you're
really interacting with API.
Even if you don't
acknowledge that fact right.
Your computer is a client
and it's sending a request.
And there's a server
somewhere that responding
to that request with some email
that you view it as a web page.
Now this is, again,
not meant to be
a comprehensive overview of
what APIs are or how APIs work.
But this hopefully
sets the stage
and gives you a little
bit of background
and the next general question.
I think that makes
sense to ask here is.
OK, well, that's great.
But as an R user
as a statistician
as an actuary as a data
scientist as an analyst
why do I care right.
Why is this something
that's important to me.
And I think there's
kind of two reasons
here that this
becomes significant.
And it goes back to
our initial conundrum
where we built this model.
And we want to give
people access to it.
But we don't want to
train the whole company
on how to use our right.
And the fact is
APIs allow the work
that you do to be used by a wide
range of tools and technologies
at that.
And that that's no
longer no longer limited
to just the language.
So I can now
essentially say, OK,
I've got this model that
we're going to work with them
will walk through an example.
This is the moment
I this model here.
And I've got another team in
my organization that's using
Python or they're using C
or they're using JavaScript
or they're using C+ or they're
using any number of tools
and they want to use my model.
Well APIs allow me to do that
in a very, very straightforward
and easy way.
So that I no longer
need to hand off
my model to be rebuilt
by another team
in another language.
But instead they can
just communicate directly
with the work that I've
done via this web API.
And this again, the idea
here is this dramatically
reduces the handoff
between the work
that you do an R
and other tools that
are being built within
your organization
by teams using other languages,
or other technology frameworks.
So with that kind of in mind,
let's talk briefly about
how Plumber works and
how Plumber creates
this bridge between
our user and developers
and other tools and
technologies here's
an example of a Plumber api
over here on the left hand
side of the screen.
And I want to I'm going
to walk through some
of the core components here.
But before I do that,
if you just take a step
back and ignore the comments.
Right, so if you just ignore
the comment that lines of code
or the commented
lines in this are code
it should look pretty
straightforward.
If you've written
R code before.
We've got a couple of
functions that we define
and we load the Plumber package
at the top of the script.
And if I look at
these functions.
There's nothing that's terribly
interesting or different
about them.
If I look at the first
function over here
it takes a single
parameter message.
And then it returns a
list just that verifies
that it received the messages.
Essentially right.
It returns a list that
says, OK, the messages
and then it echoes
back that message.
My second function here.
It doesn't take any arguments.
And instead it just returns a
histogram of some random values
that I draw from the
normal distribution.
So it's pretty easy
to reason about what
these two functions will do.
Right? Function one
is going to echo back
whatever I give
it function two is
going to give me a random
histogram of some values.
Now the real....
I think the real magic and
the real power of the Plumber
package is how it allows
me to go from these simple
R functions to
a responsive web
API in just a
couple of comments.
And that's where these
comments come into play.
So if you focus on what I have
highlighted here in this box,
you'll notice that
these comments.
Look a little bit different.
The standard are comments.
I've got the pound
somewhere the hashtag symbol
that's what is typically
used to comment things in R,
but then I follow
that with an asterisk.
And that indicates
the Plumber hey,
this is a special comment
that provides instructions
for what Plumber needs to do.
And so I can see, for example,
if I take this first comment
I give it this API
title tag and I
know that because it starts
with at symbol and an API title
and then I give the API
some sort of a name Plumber
example, a pan.
This case.
And then the next comment block
these three comments following
describe how Plumber
should use the function that
comes afterwards.
So a first comment here tells
me, gives a description of what
this function is going to do.
It's going to echo
back the input.
My second comment here
describes the parameters
of that function.
So in this case have a
single message parameter
that parameter is the message
that I'm going to echo.
And then the final
line here is perhaps
the most important because
it defines both what
types of requests.
This will respond to
as well as what path.
This particular function is
listening on and so essentially
what this says is OK if
I run this as an API.
And I make some sort of a
request to the Echo path you
see this /echo here, then
what I'm going to get back
is I'm going to get back the
response of this function
and whatever this
function does that will
be returned to
whatever client makes
a request at this echo endpoint.
And to be even more
specific that client
will make a Git request,
which we've denoted with this
get tag here.
So the idea is a right
standard our code as functions.
I use these special comments
to identify how Plumbers should
handle those functions
and then I run the API
or I plumb it,  right?
And you can see here in
this little screenshot
I've had this run API button.
And in practice, what
this looks like is this.
I click Run API, I'll get
this nice little window that
pops open over here that
shows me the API running,
and then I can try this out.
I can say, OK, here's my
message is Hello, world.
I'm going to go ahead
and try that out.
And if we scroll
down, we can see
that the output
of that message is
the out or the output
of that execution
is the output of the function
that I wrote in R.
So again, if I look
at this try this out
write my message Hello, world.
And then here at
the bottom we'll
see some JSON that
comes back that contains
the output of my
function message
the messages Hello, world.
And it really is that simple.
Right now what I've done is
I've taken my functions in R
and I've made them.
So that they're easily
accessible from other tools
and other frameworks.
So let's actually
take a look at this.
And let's consider our original
kind of situation here.
We've got this model that we
built using this penguin data
set and what we want to
do now is we want to see,
OK, is there a way for
us to expose this model.
So that others can
interact with it.
Is there a way for
us to essentially
say, OK, what if a client
makes a request with new data.
Could we just respond with
the predicted outcomes.
Could we just respond
with the predicted species
given that request and
do that automatically.
So that if somebody
in another department
has a Python script that
wants to use our model
they can just send a
request with new data.
And we can send them back
the predicted outcome.
That's what we want
to accomplish here.
So what's actually going to
flip over here to RStudio.
Now and let's go ahead
and let's build this out.
OK So what we want to do is we
want to load the final package.
And then before I
do anything else,
let's just kind of
make sure that we've
got the pieces in place that
we want to have in place.
So what I'm going
to do first here
is I'm going to create
(And zoom in a little bit)list .
I'm going to create,
just as a single endpoint
that all it does
is just verifies
that things are working.
It's not going to
do anything other
than just return some
information that says, hey,
the lights are on.
Things seem to be working.
So we'll call this, we'll
write the function here.
Like a type.
And we'll say we want
to return a list.
And we want to say, OK,
the status is that all.
And then we'll
return the time, just
so we can verify
that this is working
the way that it should be.
And if I run this function, we
could call this function status
or something like that.
And if I run this function in
R, we can see what I get back.
I get back this list.
And it tells me the
status is all good.
And it gives me this timestamp
of when that function executed
and now what I want to
do is I want to turn this
into an API endpoint.
So we'll give it a
little description here
we'll say we'll call this help.
Let's call this health check
right in the API running.
So that's our description.
And then this will
respond to get requests
at the help desk right.
So I've taken I've
written my function.
And now all I'm doing is I'm
adding these special comments
that we saw before
that tell Plumber
what to do with this function.
All right.
What do I want to do.
Well I want to call
it health check.
This is the title
and description.
I'm going to give it.
And then here's the
important piece it says, OK.
Whenever I get request
comes in and I'm not
going to get into
what different request
types are and things like that.
That's that's an exercise
for another time.
But essentially, if a request
comes into this location,
then return the results of this
function execute this function
and return the results.
And if we save this.
We can click.
Run API here.
And we'll see over here
on the right hand side,
we've got this
little interface that
shows up that allows us to see.
OK, we've got this health
check let me expand this
out a little bit.
So we can see.
All right.
So here I've got this.
Get health check it tells me
the description of the endpoint,
which is what we provided.
Right here is the API running
health check is even running
and we could try this out.
Let's come in and try this out.
There's no parameters.
I don't need to provide
any parameters here.
So I just execute this.
And here I see my response body.
And I can see directly.
In fact, let's see if we can
make this a little easier
to compare.
If I scroll up, up.
Here we go.
Here's the result of
my function in R right.
We we ran the function in
R and that's what we see.
And here is the result when
I make a request an API
request to this endpoint.
And hopefully you can see the
connection between the two.
Right I hear you
up, up top, I've
got an R list that was
created that tells me
the status of the time
and hear down below.
I have that same list except now
it's just in JSON format, which
is kind of the industry standard
for how these APIs communicate.
Now you can adjust how
this what type of response.
This an API generates
and we'll look at that
here in a little bit.
But by default Plumber will
take the output of your function
and convert it to JSON.
And that JSON data will
be returned to the client.
So here's what we here's what
we saw return to the client.
And basically what this says is
OK, we have this working right.
Is working.
We're able to see
that the APIs running.
We can try this out again,
if we wanted to write
we could execute this again.
And we see the same
result. But the timestamp
is now updated to reflect
the current time, which
in my local time is 11 23.
All right.
We're going to stop the API.
And now we're going
to keep going.
So this makes sure that.
OK, we've got all
the pieces in place.
We know what we're doing.
Now let's figure out, OK,
what do we really want to do.
What's our goal here.
Well, first of all,
I need the model.
So I've already saved the model.
We'll just read the model in.
We'll see a model is read model.
OK So I've got this model on
file that I've already saved.
We can read this in here.
Right So we've our model.
And now what I want
to be able to do
is I want to say, OK, what
if I predict my model,
and I say new data is
and I've got some JSON
data lying around.
I'll say read JSON Collins.
I don't think Clyde was OK.
So let's see Oh, we need to do.
We go.
All right.
So now if I look
at this and I'll
walk through what we did here.
But if I look what
I really want is
I want to say, OK, given my
model that I already trained
I want to be able to
give it some new data
and return the
predicted outcomes.
So in this case,
what I'm returning is
I'm returning it a
probability value for each
of the three different species.
Right So in this case
penguin 1 has a straw
where we're almost entirely
confident as 2 prediction
to our observation
two or very strongly
predicting that it's adelie.
So on and so forth.
I can see the breakdown
across each potential outcome
or each potential species
here in my output.
So this works.
This is I mean, this is how I
would generate new predictions
in R, but what I
really want is I really
want this functionality
to take place in an API.
I want somebody to be able
to just pass me some data.
And then I can pass them
back the predicted outcomes
like what I'm doing here.
So this is our goal
right here our goal
is to do this is to have this
kind of behavior in an API
endpoint.
So we've got our model in place.
We'll need to.
Let's bring in.
We've got a couple
of other packages
that we need to make
sure that they're
available in our environment
here just for the model.
So we need to bring
in the past Netlify
package for the predict function
to work to the right, the way
that we want it to.
And this is all because
of how we train the model.
And then we want to bring
in the Ranger package
because we train this model
using the Ranger package.
So this is, again, just
to remind ourselves.
This is a random forest model
that we built. We saved it out.
And now we're going
to use it in this API
that we're building OK, I've
got these pieces in place.
So now what I want is I want to
say, OK, I've got a function,
and what I want to be able
to do is I want to say,
OK, I want to
predict I've already
got my model because I've
loaded that in my environments.
I've got my model and
then I've got new data.
And this is the part.
OK, now I've got
to figure this out
because where is this
data going to come from.
Right I don't have like
it like when I run.
This is an API.
I want this data to
come from the user.
Right this is data that comes
from the client request.
So OK, let's think
about how that works.
The way that this works
and Plumber is I'm
going to have I'm going
to write my function.
So that it takes a couple
of arguments request
our IQ and response are yes.
And what this does, if I
write my function this way,
it allows me to have access to
the full request that's being
made from within my function.
Plumber will automatically
pass that request
object into my function.
And then I have access to it.
And one of the cool things
with Plumber with the latest
release of Plumber is
that you can automatically
pass incoming data.
And make it available
in the request itself.
So so for example,
if I have a user that
makes a request with
some JSON data and says,
OK, here's some here's
some information
about some new
penguins we found.
And I want to know
what their species is.
So they make this request.
Plumber will automatically
take that JSON data converted
to a data frame.
And make it available
for me to use
within the body of this function
that I'm writing right now.
So all we need to know
is we need to know.
OK, well, what.
Like where does that get stored.
And it gets stored as the
request as part of the request.
And it gets stored as
the body object attached
to this incoming request.
And in fact, we'll take
a look at the moment.
But this is essentially what
I want to be able to do.
I want to say,
OK, let's do this.
And let's say type
is probability
like we saw before right.
We're just we're just taking
this function that was our goal
and we're now putting
it inside this function
that we're going to
use within our API.
So I'm going to
say this is going
to be predict species
for new penguins
and then this is
let's say we want
to respond to POST requests
at the predict end point.
OK, excellent.
Let's let's go and run this.
I'm going to go.
I'm going to go out and
comment this out just
because this isn't a necessary
piece of what we're doing.
This is just so that
we know what we're
trying to accomplish here.
We're going to run this API.
And let's pop this
open over here.
OK So we see our health check.
Let's just verify
that that's doing
what we think it should be.
And it looks like it is.
Which is great.
That means everything's
working on the Plumber side
as far as we know.
And then let's take a look
at predict and point here.
OK, we've got this
predict end point.
We'll try it out.
OK execute OK.
We get some sort of error here.
OK And if we look at
this, this is just
an R error that's come
back to us in JSON format.
Right which is, again, a nice
kind of feature of a Plumber
is that if my arco
throws an error.
I can capture that error, and I
can gracefully return something
to user or if I don't capture
it or do anything like that,
then Plumber will
automatically take that error
message converted into JSON
and return it back to the user.
So they get some idea
of what's going on
and what's really
happening here is
I'd like I didn't
give this any data.
So this is saying,
look, I didn't
find one or more independent
variables was not
found like I didn't
find any data,
then that actually makes sense,
because I didn't I didn't
give it any data in here.
Right like I didn't.
There wasn't any part of
this where I like provided it
with some sample data.
And so now I've got to figure
out, OK, well, how do I
how can I provide
some sample data here.
Right and one of the features
that's new to Plumber
is the ability to
modify the user
interface that that appears.
And so we saw this
user interface that
showed up over you in fact, let
me just run this one more time.
So we see it.
Right So I've got
this user interface
that appears over here.
This is really,
really nice because it
means that is an R user
when I'm building my API.
And I run it.
I get a nice really clean
way to interact with the API
directly from within RStudio.
Right right here in
RStudio I can check
to see that my APIs working.
And here we go.
Right things are working.
I can check this end point.
But as we just saw if I
tried to do something like.
Check this endpoint
all of a sudden,
I'm in a little bit of a bind
because there's nothing here
that allows me to pass in data.
So what I really would like is
I'd like some way to say, OK,
how can I like, can I just
plop some JSON in here right.
Instead of instead of not
being able to do anything.
What if I could just
drop some JSON into here.
And run it that way.
And with the newest
release of Plumber
that is entirely possible.
So that entire user interface
that we're just looking at
is built around something called
the open API specification.
Now the entire open
API specification
is a massive standardization
standardized format
for defining API behavior and
endpoints and things like that.
I am not going to
spend a lot of time
going into the entirety of
what open APIs and all of that
entails.
You're certainly welcome to
look more into that on your own.
But what it means
for us as our users.
And as Plumber
users is that if we
want to enhance the capability
of our user interface
here we can do so by
doing one of two things.
We can either modify
it directly in Ar
with by modifying a
list a massive list,
or we can provide our
own specification file
and use that from within our.
So that's what we're
going to do here
and I'll show you
what this looks like.
So I'm going to create
another little section here.
I'm going to call
this at Plumber.
This is another new
feature of the package.
And basically what
this special tag does
is it allows me to take
my existing Plumber object
and modify it.
However, I want.
So I'm no longer
defining an end point,
but rather what I'm
doing is I'm saying, OK
after I've done all this stuff.
So after I've added health
check after I've added predict.
I want to further modify this
object that's being created.
And so I'm going to
say this is a function
and we'll call it PR
for my Plumber router.
And then in here,
I can modify what
I want to do to this PR object.
And this gives me
another chance to unveil
one more really great feature
of the news release of Plumber.
And that is I can now do
something like this PR pipe.
We are set API spec
and I want to say, OK,
let's get this GMO file
that I'm going to read.
And I'll show you what this
violence like in just a moment
here.
OK So let's before we
look at this yamma file.
Let's look at what
we're doing here.
I'm saying, OK Plumber
take this information
and start building
me an API router.
But now that you've
built these pieces.
So you've got this end
point you get the template.
I want to do
something else to it.
I want to take that
router and I want
to add this API
specification file.
Right and so what
I can do here is
I can either provide a named
list, which this will do
or I can modify the existing
specification that Plumber
is already building for me.
There one works.
I kind of like this
approach because it
allows me to lay out the
whole outline of what I want.
And that can be helpful.
But either one works.
So if we look at this
open API file here.
This is a llama file
that just contains
information about the API.
And notice I define like the
summary for my health check.
I defined the
summary for predict.
And if I run this.
Now we come back over
here to my Plumber file.
And we run this, you'll notice
that my descriptions have now
changed.
Right my health
check says determine
if the APIs running and
listening as expected.
And notice that
here my description
says health check is
the API running well.
Why are those two
things different.
They're different
because I overwrite
in this GMO file what
that description should
be noticed in here.
I say determine if the
APIs running and listening
is expected and that is what
we see listed in my interface.
So I have effectively
overwritten
some of what I already did by
providing this new definition
file.
But in addition to overwriting
some of that information.
I've also described that I want
to be able to pass and JSON
data to this predict end point.
And so if I come over
here and open this up.
It tells me here.
Look, the request
body should be Jason.
And here's an example
of what that JSON
data should look like.
And if I try this out.
I can come in here.
And I edit this,
I could say, well,
what if we said
that you won tender.
What if we said 54 40 or 50
40, whatever the case is right.
I can come in and I can pass
my own data into this end point
now and try it out.
Right we can execute this.
And here, we see that we have,
once again, an internal error.
And this is because if we
come back over to our API
if off for just a moment, we're
passing in only a single value.
And it's being passed as a
vector and set up a data frame.
So if we just change
this one piece and say
we want this to be a data frame.
Now let's run the API one
more time, try this out.
Here's our data
that we're passing
in let's execute on our data.
And here we see our response
is a JSON object that
contains the
predicted probability
for each associate species.
So in this case, this particular
penguin is almost a toss
up right.
We're not super sure which one
it is it may be a chin strap
but it's a fairly even
split across all three
potential outcomes here.
And what's good
about this is now
we have exactly what we
were describing originally.
Right if I come back up
here for just a moment.
And look at what
my goal was right.
I want to enable an external
user to give me some data.
And then I want to
be able to return
to them the
associated likelihood
that that particular
set of data matches up
with each of the
three species that
are our potential outcomes.
And that's exactly
what I've done here.
Now To recap right just to
revisit this idea one more
time.
We have specified our own
specification file this yama
file that identifies all
the details of how this user
interface should be laid out.
And that's where I can.
That's that's what enables me
to have the ability to input
the JSON data needed to generate
a response from this end point.
So all from within
RStudio itself.
I'm able to build my API
and I'm able to come over
here and verify that
that APIs working the way
that it needs to OK.
That's been a little
bit to swallow.
I know that maybe we've
gotten into some detail
that we didn't necessarily
need to or want to get into.
But I think it's
useful to understand
how some of these pieces work.
Is it necessary to change
the EPA specification file.
No is it something
that you have to do.
No right.
You can do this.
You can operate just
fine without it.
Now granted that
might mean that you
need to find some other way
to make a request to your API
to verify that you are predict.
End point is working
the way that you expect.
But there are lots
of tools that work
that will enable you
to interact with APIs
and a really nice kind
of clean interface.
Postman is one that
I use regularly.
And there are
several others that
exist as well, that allow you
to generate requests and see
responses and things like that.
So you need to make
these modifications.
No but if you want
to, you certainly can.
Let's take a look
at one more thing
here that I think is, again,
maybe a little bit extra,
but I think it's useful to
know the default interface.
I going to run this
API one more time.
The default interface
here is swagger
and I see that up
here on the top.
Let him in court.
This is the swagger
interface swagger.
It has been around
for quite a while.
Open API the
specification kind of
grew out of some of the
efforts that went into swagger
and everything they got.
But essentially now
what we have is swagger
is we'll interpret
my specification.
And give me this interface.
There are other
alternatives to swagger
that exist today that
do the same thing.
They create an
interface for me to use.
And now within Plumber
given the latest release
it's entirely possible to use
one of those other systems
instead of using swagger itself.
So for example,
if I wanted to use
that there's a library or
a viewer called rapid arc.
So if I wanted to use rapid arc.
I could come in here.
There's an R package.
It's not released on CRAN it's
only on GitHub at this point,
there's an artifact.
It's called rapid arc
that I can install here.
And I could load here.
And then further down.
I could say, let's do PR set
docs and we'll say docs is OK.
We'll save these changes.
And now if I come back
and run my API again,
you'll see that my
interface looks different.
I have the same
functionality right.
I can open up this one
I can try this out.
I can see the response.
I can open up this one.
Come in here, I can
see the example data.
I can try this out.
We see the response right.
So I get my functionality
remains the same,
but maybe I have a preference
over which particular UI use
when I'm experimenting with the
end and working with my API.
And you have the
flexibility now and Plumber
to be able to define those.
One more thing that I
want to look at here
is while we've got this open.
We have this built an example
here that gives us a sink.
The measurements for a
single penguin but I've
also got this job there.
Excuse me.
This JSON data here that
contains measurements
for several penguins.
And if we copy this in
here and try this out,
we'll see that our response.
Now includes predicted
output for all the penguins
that provided input for right.
So I now have this
long JSON object
that contains all the
information for the penguins
that I provided.
OK, let's get one
more thing here.
Let's come back into
my Plumber file.
And let's say, OK
instead of Jason though,
let's say I just I
really want I really want
CSV data to come out of this.
Right So we could
say at serialize
our CSV this tells
Plumber look when
you return the output of this
function don't return it.
As Jason returned
it as a CSV file.
And if I run this again
or return this as CSV did.
And if I run this
again and try this.
Let's bring in all of
our observations again,
you can see now instead
of this JSON object.
I have comma separated
values for my response.
Right So I can adjust what
specifically is returned
to the client from within here.
We're going to take a step
back from this for a moment.
We'll revisit our API
here in just a minute.
Let's go ahead and stop this.
We'll save these changes here.
And let's come back, of
course, to our slides.
OK So just to recap
and kind of summarize
what we looked at here
several new features
have landed in the
Plumber package
with the latest release.
The tidy interface.
So the ability to build your
APIs by piping from one command
to the next is new.
We read barely touched on that.
But that's something
that you can
explore more if you're
interested in the ability
to automatically pass and pass
the incoming request body.
So that it's available for
downstream execution is new,
which we saw that when we
said, OK, the request body
contains the past values that
we're getting from the client.
There's support for new
serialized hours and the way
that you define serialized
is greatly simplified.
The open API
specification, we look at
can adjust that in a
couple of different ways
by providing your own file
or by modifying the existing
list that are is working with.
You can customize the UI.
So instead of using swagger
which is the default.
You can use rapidly like
you could use Reebok
as a handful of different
customer UIs you can use.
And last but not least
plumbed the Plumber hex
logos got a face lift.
This was on the title slide.
So you probably
already come across it.
But there's the new
Plumber logo that
done that accompanies
this update the top.
OK So now we've got this API.
It's running.
It's doing what we want.
We mission accomplished right.
We're able to take in some data.
We're able to
generate predictions
we're able to return that
data back to the client.
All is good, except
for one thing
we are still the
bottleneck right
like this is like I'm just
working off my laptop right
now.
And so when I'm
running this API.
It's just running locally
here on my own machine.
And that works for
development purposes.
And testing purposes.
But what happens when
I now want to say,
look Sarah and engineering
is ready to make
a request to this API.
Well I don't want my laptop to
always be the one thing that's
servicing these requests.
I need some way to deploy this.
So that it's an input in an
environment where it's always
listening and
available to clients
that are trying to make
that request again,
whether those clients or other
parts of my organization,
or maybe I've
built an API that's
just generally
publicly available
and is being used
by who knows who.
There are a couple
of options that
exist for deploying Plumber
APIs are RStudio Connect is
a professional product
that's developed and built
by RStudio that allows for
easy deployment of Plumber API.
We'll look at an example of
that here in just a moment.
You can deploy you can wrap up
these guys inside of a Docker
container and then deploy them
into an environment that's
suitable for that
type of deployment.
And then there's some nice
kind of helper functions
that used to exist in
the Plumber package
and have now been offloaded
to a new package called
Plumber deploy that allows
you to easily deploy
to DigitalOcean.
And that package may evolve to
include other deployment points
as well.
So you've got a host
of different options.
I want to spend a
couple of minutes just
to talk about ask you to
connect as one potential way
of deploying these Plumber
guys after you connect
is, like I mentioned, it's
a professional product
that we create and
develop here at RStudio.
It allows for easy push
button deployment of things
created an R and Python.
It handles dependency
management.
So all of your packages
and dependencies
come along for the ride.
It allows you to adjust
how your API scales
how it responds to
concurrent requests
how new processes are generated.
Things of that nature.
It integrates with Git
and GitHub a GitHub.
So you can automatically
deploy from repositories.
You can specify who has
permission and authentication
to access things like
API and dashboards
and things like that.
And then like I said,
in addition to Plumber
you can also publish
R Markdown documents
and reports China application
Huber notebooks flask
streamlined Python applications
and other additional other
additional pieces of content.
And if you'd like
to learn more, you
can visit our website our
connect which details what
RStudio Connect is and
it provides a little bit
of additional context.
But what I'd like
to do now is I'd
like to take a look
at RStudio Connect.
So if I come here.
This is RStudio Connect let's
come in to the landing page
here.
So here's what I see when I come
into RStudio Connect something
like this.
And let's go through the process
of publishing this API that we
built. Now I've set up this API
that we built in RStudio to BI
Publisher will you get.
So if I come in
here and say, OK,
let's import this
from a Git repository
let's pull in the
repository name.
So what is let's see.
OK So here's the
repository for that.
I find it really quick.
So get I've got this
repository that I keep
talks and things that I do in.
And then this is the Plumber
webinar 2020 repository.
Click next year.
This will look to see what
branches are available.
I've only got a single branch
available there right now.
Click next.
And then this will look for
deployable sub directories.
In this case, we only have one.
It's looking for this manifest
file that I previously created.
And then we'll call this
former pay to play content.
And now this is deploying
our content, we go.
Let's open this up and
see what it looks like.
OK So here we have
our API running.
I can open this up
and say, OK, let's go.
Anybody can come in here and
view this if they want to.
Here's my health check.
Let's verify that
this is working.
Looks like it is gives me back
the information that I expect.
Let's check out our other end
point or predict end point.
It looks like it's doing
what we wanted to do.
There we go.
We see our CSV output here.
And all is well.
And good.
Right I've got everything.
Everything is working the
way that I expected to.
And just to illustrate this.
Right if I so one way to
quickly and easily demonstrate
how an external either tool
or framework or language
can make a request to this API
if I open this API up here.
Here we go.
Let's take a look at this.
So now I've opened this up.
So that it's just open
kind of in its own isolated
environment.
And if I instead am going
to darks go to help check me
this might be a
little small to see.
And I apologize.
But I'm just visiting the URL
and then adding health check
to the end of it.
And basically what this
means is my browser
is now going to make a request
to the health check end.
And if we do this
my browser shows
me the JSON that's coming back
from that health check point.
So without any sort of like
fancy bells and whistles
I've just now made a request to
this API from my web browser.
And I'm now seeing the results
of that request rendered
here and in front of us.
OK So what does that
want to highlight here
before we wrap things up.
All is well.
And good.
Right my guys running.
I can give other
developers or other teams
within my organization, I
can give them the information
they need to make requests.
This API, they can make those
requests my API will respond
back to them and all is good.
But now let's say,
OK, I published this.
It's great.
And then I get an email and
a couple of days says, look,
we started using an
interacting with your API.
We notice that is giving us
back comma separated values.
Right and we'd really
prefer to get Jason
like we can pass the CSV data.
But our platforms
built around Jason,
could you provide us with
Jason as a response instead
of these comma separated values.
And we've already
seen how to do that.
If we come back
into RStudio here.
And take a look.
Right if we can if we
take this serialized
and say instead of
CSV let's just do
Jason and Jason is
the default right.
So if I deleted
this whole thing.
It would still be Jason.
But we could save this change.
He's OK.
We're we're going to
return JSON data here.
Let's go and save that.
And then let's come in to
see if I can pull it open.
Here we go.
Let's come in to get and
make Ken commit this change.
We'll say, OK, we're going to
update to these song serial
serialization.
Commit that, we'll go
ahead and push this change
to get and now let's
go ahead and grab
our big bunch of penguins.
And if we come back over
here RStudio Connect
will check every
15 minutes or so
by default to see
what changes have
been made to the repository.
But I'm also just going
to manually kick it off
and say, OK, let's just
check for any updates
in the repository.
Hey some changes were found.
We're going to redeploy this.
OK We're ready to go.
And now if I come in and
try this and point out
will change our example
to include all this.
We can see that my response
is now Jason instead of CSV
and I didn't have
to do anything.
All I did was make a change
and commit that change
to my Git repository
like I normally
do in my regular workflow.
And ask you to connect
will automatically
pick up on that change
redeploy the content
and make it available so that
I can make the change push it
to GitHub and email that
developer back and say
it should be fixed now you
should now be able to receive
Jason all right.
So in conclusion, if you're
interested in learning more
about Plumber and the tools
that we've talked about today.
Here's a whole list
of resources you
can go to visit the first list.
The first resource listed
here is the Plumber website.
And then a bunch of
different Git repositories
so the Plumber get a repository.
If you run into like issues
or questions with the package
you can go there to see
if that issue has already
been submitted.
Or you can submit
your own issue.
The second repository
listed here
is a collection of just
example APIs to build from.
If you are looking
for some examples
to get started with a Plumber
deploy I briefly mentioned
currently has the
DigitalOcean functions
for deploying DigitalOcean.
This rapid R repository
is something we use today.
So that we could change
the user interface
that we saw with Plumber.
The material that
we looked at today.
So the example files and
everything like that.
The slides will
be made available
at the webinars GitHub
repository that's listed here.
So look for that to be
published there shortly.
And then the community.
There are a community site has
a Plumber group or a Plumber tag
that you can follow if you're
interested in questions
being asked about Plumber.
If you have
questions on your own
you'd like to ask
to the community.
You can do.
So there.
And then finally,
our state RStudio
has our global conference
coming up in January.
Barrett, who is,
again joined us today
is going to be presenting some
additional new functionality
with Plumber and asynchronous
execution at that.
And that's an entirely virtual
conference that you can attend
and I would encourage
you to attend as well,
especially if you're interested
in asynchronous Plumber
execution as that
is what's buried
is going to be
speaking about there.
And then finally, just thank
you again for your time,
for joining us today.
I appreciate this
opportunity to present
on Plumber and all
the new features
that we've added to the package.
We're really excited about
the work that's being done.
If you have questions, if you
have things you want to discuss
feel free to reach out.
Reach out on our your community.
I monitor that site
quite frequently.
And respond to questions
or comments at posts there.
And again, just from all
of us here in RStudio.
Thank you very much
for joining us today.
I think we've got a couple of
minutes here for questions.
And so I'm going to pause and
pull open the questions here
to see if there's anything
that remains to be answered.
There's a question
that came in that
says, are there any
suggestions suggested tools
or packages to
integrate security
to secure access to API.
Really good question.
There is not anything unlike
the R package standpoint
that I've really tested.
I know that a while ago.
And I'm trying to remember the
name I came across a group that
was building an R
package that the goal was
to provide security
some security
functionality for Plumber API.
I haven't revisited
that in quite a while.
And in fact like I
said, I don't quite
remember what the name of
that repository or package
was going to be.
So I don't know where
things ended up there.
I don't know how
far that made it.
Because of Plumber's
flexibility.
You can handle like security
and authentication and things
like that yourself.
It becomes I don't want
to say tricky, but it just
you have to think
carefully about it
to make sure that you
don't leave yourself
open to like security
vulnerabilities
but you could certainly for
example, have a filter in place
that says, look, if a
user if a request is
made without a specific header
or without a specific token
then that doesn't get
passed through that request
gets rejected and for is
out or something like that.
You can certainly do that
on your own within Plumber
but there's no like I
said, to my knowledge,
is there's no kind of out
of the box package or tool
that does that for you.
That being said,
our RStudio Connect
does have an API key
based authentication.
So if I, for example, take my.
Let me just come back
here for a minute.
If I take my little
API here and set it.
And instead said, look, you
have to log in to view this,
then that would require users
to submit a request with an API
key as one of their headers
and ask you don't connect
will verify that key and
verify that the key belongs
to a user that is allowed
permission to this API.
And then pass that through.
But again, that's
something that's
enforced on the
Narciso connect level
and not being enforced at the
plumbing level Plumber is still
just responding as
usual ask you to connect
is acting as the
gatekeeper in front of it
to filter out requests
that are invalid.
Great question.
Can you completely customize
the look of the API
that makes it look
prettier for users
or are you stuck with
the template you showed.
So those template.
So we looked at swagger
and we looked at rapid arc.
Those are based off of the
open API specification.
Basically what those do.
Those are frameworks
that take that open API
specification, which is
basically that big yellow file,
we looked at.
And then generate a
UI layer on top of it.
And then the nice
thing about Plumber
is it connects the UI layer
to the underlying our process
that's running the API.
Right So I've got this nice
direct link between OK,
I've got this API running.
And now I can interact with
it like we see here right.
I've got this nice
sort of UI layer.
I'm like, how do I have
a lot of experience
with each of those
individual pieces.
So for example, we're
using rapid eye care right.
I don't know how customizable.
The look and feel of this
particular framework is there.
I do know that there are
a handful of frameworks
that exist today.
And there's kind of more
being created almost
to feel like all the time.
And so it's possible
that some may
provide additional flexibility.
I don't I don't
entirely know the answer
to that particular question.
Can Plumber dictate rate limits.
Another excellent question.
Not out of the box.
There's nothing
specific in Plumber
where you can specify like an
at a rate limit tag or setting
or anything like that.
You could build in
rate limiting yourself.
It would require some
additional legwork
because you'd have to have
some way of identifying
know how are you rate
limiting or you rate
limiting to a specific user.
And then you'd have
some sort of cash rate.
Keep track of what
their rate limited
or what their current
consumption is.
And then check that
consumption against the limit
that they've been
given and provide
messaging around that limit.
You can build all
that and apply it.
I'm not saying that
it's not possible.
I'm just saying there's
not anything built
in that allows
you to rate limit,
but you could certainly
build that functionality
into your eyes by using
tools, the Plumber provides.
OK Yes OK.
So once deployed how do
you submit the new data
to the model API.
It seems unwieldy
to just like passing
a giant browser you are.
Totally correct.
Right in most cases,
these APIs I'm
going to be interacted
with the web browser.
But rather somebody else.
So you maybe you've got a
front end developer that's
writing JavaScript or
you've got a mobile app
developer developing and swept
or whatever the case is all
of these frameworks have their
own libraries packages tools
for building and
sending API requests
and those developers
would often do that.
So for example, as an r
user the httr our package
is what you would use
to build a request.
So if you were an R user
submitting a request to you.
I could submit a
request to this API.
We just built right.
I could use the httr package to
build that request, including
the new data that's going to be
passed to the predict end point
and send that request over.
And then the response
will come back
and I could work
with it from there.
So in most cases,
the nice thing is
when you start talking about
API as most developers will
understand how to
work with that.
And they'll have
their own framework
that they use for
sending requests.
And the nice thing
is those requests
will all be formatted
the same way because http
is a standard format.
So your API.
It doesn't matter
if the request is
coming from in our
script using httr
if it's coming from Python
using the request module.
It doesn't matter if it's coming
from going it doesn't matter.
It doesn't matter.
The request comes in the
API executes and returns
the response.
And in lots of frameworks
have their own way
of making those requests OK.
Last question.
I'll answer here in the
last minute that we've got.
What is the advantage of using
an API versus shiny apps.
Really good question.
Shiny applications
are really best suited
for like human interaction.
Right So if I've got
a shiny application.
I'm going to come in here.
And I'm going to interact with
it as an individual right.
As API.
It's not as if they
expected that users
are going to come in here
and interact with the API.
This way they might do it
a little bit right just
to check some things,
but in most cases,
an APIs going to be interacted
with programmatically.
So I might build a Plumber API.
So that another tool or
that my company developed
can use my model or can reuse
the business logic that I've
implemented in my API.
I might use a shiny app.
So that another user
can view my model.
If that makes sense, right.
So that the distinction
here is who's the end user.
In one case for shiny
it's another human
that's interacting with
my application for API.
It's most like
another tool that's
interacting with my
application or with my API.